le glyphosate peut-il disparaître des
campagnes une difficulté quand on parle
d'agriculture de conservation des sols
selon cette technique les labours
limiter au maximum mais les mauvaises
herbes elle se développe elle sont
éradiqués père des produits
phytosanitaires dont les doses sont
optimisés cette agriculture et la plus
forte consommatrice de glyphosate en
france selon l'inra et les résultats
d'une expérimentation menée depuis trois
ans à montrésor par une association
d'agriculteurs ont été rendus publics
hier pour les conclusions et bien la fin
du glyphosate mettrait en péril le
modèle économique des exploitations
alors que l'intérêt serait mesurée pour
l'environnement les explications de
tristan rickli
pour mener les tests quatre parcelles de
sarrazin avec et sans glyphosate une
demi dose de glyphosate et enfin avec
désherbage mécanique sur trois ans
l'objectif de l'étude comparé ces
différentes pratiques en conditions
réelles d'exploitation pour déterminer
si oui ou non les agriculteurs peuvent
se passer de cet herbicide décrié
conclusion les parcelles sont glyphosate
serait moins productives jusqu'à 80%
aucune des solutions alternatives ne
ressort des essais elles peuvent être
efficace ponctuellement mais à mettre en
place sur toute une ferme c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué et puis sur le retour au
travail du sol savent d impact aussi
négatif alors on réduise sur le
glyphosate mais on n'est pas forcément
plus efficace sur le changement
climatique
l'étude est financée par le ministère de
l'agriculture et l'institut de la
recherche agronomique porté par
l'association à pas qui promeut
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
leur démarche privilégiez le chimique au
travail mécanique car celui-ci
présenterait un inconvénient de taille
les tracteurs et de 15 à 30 %
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre en
plus
avec les résultats qui sont tenues au
bout de trois ans en fait c'est que
c'est avec l'application de
d'une dose de glyphosate qui est la
meilleure en termes économiques et
rentabilité de propreté des parcelles
aussi les expérimentations s'achève sur
cette plateforme mais continue à
l'échelle nationale un nouveau projet
nommé sol y flor on va voir le jour
objectif explorer la piste de
l'utilisation de couverts végétaux entre
deux périodes de culture